did you well here comes Ricky now yep
okay let's get ready oh [ __ ] let me get
my interview get your intro we'll get
the horns
okay I didn't realize we have all that
food their prices stinks it does it's
things like fast food in here yeah okay
let's take some of the without is I mean
while I'd already stinks green in here
all right yeah bringing the Travis bring
it to the Travis 10j horn and war Travis
are you ready for the mute with the
music course okay okay we have to get
the music ready hello Ricky we have been
instructed to read your introduction
your people said in intro yes no we have
no listen to the music it's a it's a
it's a celebration
Ricky is the creator of the office
extras and the Ricky Gervais show he is
1/8 Baptist 3 Golden Globes and two
Primetime Emmys for acting writing
directing and stand up his old podcasts
have been downloaded 600,000 times ricky
homes ricky holds the record for the
fastest selling stand-up tour of all
time with the first 100,000 tickets
going in nine minutes he has sold 2.4
million tickets worldwide and plays msg
this wednesday night never to keep it
going Travis Netflix have acquired the
rights to humanity for an undisclosed
sum said to be the highest fee ever paid
for a UK stand-up special that's true as
well but I'm not gonna tell you what it
is his new radio show Ricky Gervais is
deadly serious launches tomorrow well
that song I'm sorry that's all factual I
was terrified it was gonna be this sort
of like a pinion as though there's one
one website the most influential
comedian since Charlie Chaplin and I
want to go well who says that I'd much
rather be compared to Fatty Arbuckle
anyway just talking beep well we've had
a staff issue for the day we heard and
we eat chick-fil-a this morning I've
never had it
Jim is a you love this Jim is actually
gaining four pounds or six pounds four
to six pounds for a movie role and so
for the last week and a half he's been
obsessing over eating nothing but snack
I have been eating okay what what what
listen if sorry what does for
pound-for-pound know it's on your penis
it's all I can know that I just know
there have to be a little bit heavier so
I just made a decision I'm gonna try to
put on like four to six parents all I
can do in like two who's online 10 days
notice
right it wasn't like I had like a time
where I could do it so I'm just eat like
a pig
trying to feel it I already lost a belt
loop so I'm fattening up just a little
bit and I'll take the start start losing
again but so far this morning for
breakfast he had a bag of cheese it's
four Twix bars a chicken biscuit chicken
biscuits - but what you might have you
know you ain't look so fat and bloated
or just bigger just a little bit messier
than I look like I'm just too skinny I
think I'm not 100% sure about it I just
made a decision to do it I have a window
I know I have a brief window so I'm
gonna do it in the window great good but
it's funny I mean yeah I mean then what
but didn't you work so hard
yeah I'd never do that I either way for
a role because I just think if I'm not
what oh I don't know it takes I know
obviously I'd probably get fit for a
role but I wouldn't lose weight for a
role or gain weight for a role but it's
I get fit for role because I think oh
this is someone gonna make me fit which
is good right it'll benefit me even a
movie you're also in a different place
than I am though like they seek you out
when I like although I'll tell you off
the air this independent thing I'm doing
it's like it's a very small part yeah
but I still wanna I still wanna look it
was good though that's good that's good
I don't want to jinx it that's part okay
I don't jinx okay great I've got me a
cutout anyway yeah but it's fine to eat
wherever you want I'm enjoying it yeah I
know that is that's the that's the easy
bit putting on weight right I mean I
still struggle because I vote aye
I think I can beat the system right so I
think when I I sort of lost weight by
just working out okay and this was like
10 years ago but now I still eat and
drink too much because I refuse to give
anything out including alcohol which is
like five six hundred carros tonight
just wasted Calibre's right but I
physically I can't work out an hour and
a half each day now because I'm too old
and broken so I'm just so what is the
same but there's yeah exactly
so it's because it's 80% diet isn't it
right so if you could if you if I just
like if I just stop drinking wine every
night I'd just lose weight without doing
any exercise right you're like luckily
I'm special this doesn't apply to me
what's the point what's the point yeah
the hardest food what's the hardest food
to keep from shoving your face well I
suppose sort of salty fatty carbs things
you know like cheese on toast is just
amazing it's [ __ ] for naught it's
incredible it's just like oh God
anyway you can transyl's we're gonna die
soon yeah exactly nuts probably means
I'm just sick and tired of looking a
certain way without a shirt my whole
life I've been obsessed with looking in
myself on the side in the mirror and I
can't stop looking it's all I do is look
at my fat well I realized I was getting
fat again right is where I just taped
the special all right and when I look in
the mirror you look straight on it
doesn't look too bad but when you're
walking around on stage you see yourself
from the side you have [ __ ] me how
many chins is that what's the face
because you can fall is I think so glad
you make yourself look better in the
mirror yeah you somehow you find a way
that it looks okay and then you see at
once there you go Jesus Christ who's the
fat guy with the short legs and the
[ __ ] I love that when that chin goes
straight to your chest right they used
to go in and have a throat and now when
you look in the mirror though you like
stick your face out and you'd like tense
your chest it's okay because you can't
see yourself from the side mirror I had
a guy tell me I look like I was wearing
a beekeeper mask it is humiliating but
you do catch it congratulations shooting
the special man the [ __ ] night of the
hour is really good we saw it last time
you were here and Ricky is going to be
at the garden this Wednesday at the the
theater at Madison Square Garden he's
got dates coming up which we're gonna
give away some tickets for okay yeah
which they gave us we don't really can't
get these tickets but yeah I think we
asked far enough in advance for five
pairs for this Wednesday and not to one
person of course and then we also have a
October 30th and November first the
Dolby Theatre in LA those are almost
sold out so
we actually I think I probably decent
seats for those yeah great and you got
San Francisco in Seattle coming up is
that once you shoot though like once you
shoot the special don't you want to kind
of be done with the material like you'll
wash up the tour you do and you still
improve it and there's already even the
night after this I film this special I
came up with an ad-lib and I thought
that would have been great yeah you
can't go back because you film two
nights and I've never not been happy
with a special but it's never been the
greatest night of the tour right you
know just because you're relaxed like
you're in the zone when you're taping
I'm already thinking about it and I
think I have I done that bit if I did
that back there now I did that bit
better last night and to the you know to
anyone else they could intelligence
between that one in the night before
then I offer after but to me I you know
I think the ideal thing would be to
someone to take me and not tell me
they're taping it and that would be the
best special or just tape every show
every show yeah yeah I know air tour
yeah yeah didn't Rock do that didn't he
tape bit solution because is yeah didn't
his costumes changed yeah that was the
best yeah he kind of wanted to go from
three different locations and make it
visually obvious that he was doing that
right but I don't know if that's good or
bad to do I didn't see the special I
think he just tape it one one one PI so
I type it two nights always and it's
always usually being one night you can
so you can mix and match but I don't
think I've ever mixed it's always been
one night was clearly better than
another night all the way through I'm so
[ __ ] crazy I'll take a bit like look
the setup worked better on the 7:30 show
but the middle part worked better at the
time I remember I remember because you
also you see it and you think I fluffed
that or but then you cut to the laugh
and I think all did that work and I
think we'll leave it there laughing so
they got it sure so people must get it
but it's honestly it's it's forensic
when I get into it it's like mad I just
I see him I like my lips like touches my
tooth for a second and I think oh can we
cut on Jesus no one cares no one cares I
know but we used because you know it so
well but the more important than any of
that is just a flow and an attitude
yeah important than fluffing lines or
it's just setting up if you're in the
moment it people go with it is yeah
leave the mistakes it's like
I always say Midnight Cowboy I'm walking
here that was a mistake and it made it
on camera yeah I just drove through how
you say that every night it's great
insight thanks a lot yeah mistakes are
lovely and glorious and and they just
work and you can't even explain them but
you know you've got to really keep
you've sort of got to keep the script
because it works when you've done a
hundred shows you don't want to start
thinking I'm gonna change it up tonight
because they're filming you want to go
oh my god it's killed for the last yeah
I want to do that you know so but yeah
no it's good it's just when is it coming
out of you don't know I probably spring
okay yeah are you happy with this set
where'd you shoot it
London oh you did shoot yeah I'm happy
with it because yeah I mean again I can
tell the difference when I play London
for 13 nights right then when I go to a
place I've been before and you know I
have to keep him quiet cuz I haven't
been there before but that doesn't mean
it's a bad time that doesn't mean I'm
better and people watching at home they
don't care that the audience couldn't
wait to see me because I hadn't seen
before they were well out cuz the
special they don't care about the
audience when they're watching at home
dunno I mean I don't even shoot the
audience I you don't see the audience
here one of my specials do you know it's
funny I did the same thing I want the
black I don't want to see I don't want
Comedy Central laughter cut oh but the
only reason I started filling a teeny
bit of those I [ __ ] myself in the Edit
and going to edit with nothing it's like
it you can only kind of like jump cut
there was no way to do it probably or
there are cameras and I do behind me but
you can't see the audience because it's
black with the two spotlights right in
your face so you see the back of me for
an O so I use the I of course I used or
everything I can for the Edit point but
what I mean I said I don't do those
hokey shots when it goes the audience
really laughs and we [ __ ] the Ihram
laughs yeah and also why do you need why
you need to tell the people watching oh
they were laughing so you should really
write you know I was like who's that guy
I know in the audience you just you just
you just want to give him a taste of
what it was like to be there um but you
can never get that never you can never
get that and when you go to a comedy
show it's not like you like look around
the audience to be like what's his face
look like when he's laughing I never see
that guy why I know I think the audience
laughs more if they know they're in
total blackness and they joke and relax
and yeah for a comedy club pirate it's
it's private yeah I do think so but um
yeah I am I just want to what what's
great about the special is that you
can't play to everyone in the world it's
literally impossible I died before I
could play to everyone so you know I do
I'd you know do as many major cities as
I can and and then it's sort of then so
it's more a document really it's more of
a document for people to you know but
you can't replace their live experience
and that's good and that's what's that's
what's great about everything everything
has happened in the world where
everything could be downloaded copied
every you can't you can't download going
to see a comic live that's what's that's
and that can never change yeah there is
something about being in the room I like
I don't go to many concerts but there is
something about being in the room it's
just it's a nice feeling and it is
different than its heightened as well
and you get everything you just you
understand everything more I think
everything makes sense to be there and
in the moment and not not comedic Lee
but as an event as a you know as an
experience you know I love it now it's
my favorite thing I do now stay out
honestly I I want to call myself a
stand-up now I don't I don't want to
call myself a comedian or right director
before that's why it's been seven years
because I always thought that it was my
you know the the third string to my bow
and it got put back you know more
important things came along sitcom or a
film but now is nothing more important
to me I want to start straightaway on a
new stand-up show why I [ __ ] love it
now there's nothing like it
and because I'm such a I don't know I
want to owe to everything I'm such a
control freak and I can't stand anyone
not let me do exactly what I want
there's nothing like stand up for that
you know even if you get your own way on
a sitcom I feel you still
to go you have to wait for the money you
have to wait for the casting to say
when's it going out can it go
whereas I - I'd say I'm playing in that
town I want to go to that town I'm
playing it tomorrow is the tickets you
know yes there's nothing and you can say
what you [ __ ] won it's such a
privilege it's such a and I'm so up on
freedom of speech now more than I've
ever been
do you feel more like did you feel do
you feel more legit as a comic yeah
that's the other thing that's the other
thing I I certainly realize now oh I was
okay before but I wasn't good I was okay
and now I think I'm good and now and and
that shouldn't be a revelation that it
takes 15 years to be a good stand-up
it's a [ __ ] really tough it I'll say
art form but it's more of a science
because it works or it doesn't
so there's so many things to know and
and probably science though is that the
theory changes every night like what
worked last night all of a sudden it
stinks tonight it's like what happened
like science is provable every way is
you much real but that you don't you
don't get that once if you're doing a
theater or arena tour you don't get that
because once you've worked it once
you've you know done the warm-up so
you've done 20 gigs and it works it
doesn't then not work you can have
things that go wrong like as a squeaky
door or people you know it oh that the
time was wrong so people were you know
you can have these there but once once
the joke works to 3000 people
it doesn't stop working to 3000 people
you have to [ __ ] it up yourself I think
that's true and I have many times this
all of a sudden I don't believe it
anymore and it's [ __ ] just stinks
yeah jokerz but I started doing my act
in Reverse I actually have been opening
with my closing and going backwards
because just to keep it fresh and so it
doesn't get boring yeah I don't do that
I sometimes I don't give things a chance
you know cuz usually when I write it's
quite it's quite instinctive um and I go
out there and I roughly do it and it
roughly works and then it all roughly
works and then it all well he works
better and it works better and better
and better
if someone doesn't work the first time
I'd look at it and I think is it worth
it everything else is why am i I'm not
belligerent I don't think are they're
wrong this is going to work one day I
usually just I've got you know you
spread other stuff and you have your
favorite thing and you spread
that so it's difficult it's d-iii I
don't treat it like a I've had a joke
that has not worked really at all and
I'm like it hurts me so much that I
can't make it work you just love it so
much I just there's something there and
I'm missing it and I know it yeah I
asked the audience what's wrong with
this and they elicit it worked out Shar
was like an hour thing at the saw place
called the FAP like [ __ ] can't we just
do an hour and they're paying five bucks
so they know you're just playing around
and I I'm like why does that joke stay
and they told me why and I laughed
because I was giving the total opposite
message in the joke that I thought I
wasn't clear oh really what Ana
ambiguous terms it said the wrong my
wording sucked and it's like I I know
what I'm trying to say but I can't say
it right I'm just not saying did you
make it better no cuz I forgot what the
guys answer was my follow up again it's
just not working is it come drinking
it's just it hasn't worked quite wow
I've realized what it was was that they
didn't believe the premise like I've
said you know when so and so right and
it might be a true story but it's really
obscure you can't you can't educate and
then get a laugh out of it there needs
to be there needs to be a time between
the education and and then the gag right
and sometimes if they don't know about
someone they don't but it's almost like
you set something up with like it's
taken for granted that this is true and
the audience's are given convinced of
that I did a thing where I was saying
how old everything's worse now like
terrorists are worse you know Isis you
know off the chart has no talking to
them IRA they used to give you a phone
call right no I don't think enough
people knew that the IRA used to call up
and warn sure they'd say a bomb in a pub
and then I said Isis were like oh we're
gonna cut your head off and I'm gonna
die kill me IRA was like we're gonna
shoot ya what in the head now in the
knees and that's another thing they used
to do is write a shoot in performance
but I'm talking to 25-year olds right
and they go I don't know what that means
what do you mean shoot them in the knees
you can't go back and go so listen the
IRA used to shoot people in the knee
that's right really funny after I
explained it yeah after you explained
you can't assume no
you have to you have to incorporate
knowledge in the joke unless it's so
well known you'd have to worry about it
but you can't do a reference that you
know about if they don't know that
reference the jokes crude yeah
what's got you on a on free speech now
more than ever because you said
performing stand-up it's just got you
know everything everything that's
happened in the world yeah that the
outrage the Twitter as you know I'm you
know magnified and amplified it and but
I just I can't get every day I explained
to someone what freedom of speech means
particular in the context of comedy and
particular in the context of a joke that
a joke about a bad thing isn't
necessarily as bad as the bad thing it's
not even necessarily condoning the bad
thing it could be aunty the bad thing
people don't look at the actual joke
they see the taboo thing and they go you
can't talk about that and I think that's
ridiculous we can talk about anything we
talk about anything now so welcome and
that's what a joke is a joke is a very
quick discussion so do you feel like
you're encountering that more now not
like people come now that you can no I'm
not I'm cuz I'm I am belligerent against
that I go against it and people get it
people get it I set it up and I do it
intelligently I don't just go out there
to try and offend and go let's talk
about the worst ever and joke about it
because I'm always you know with with a
comedian
we are considered I don't go out there
just a shot I go out there to to fight a
taboo and hopefully come down on the
right side but I think it's it's almost
easier this time because I think they
know me now they've known me for 15
years so they know what I'm doing right
I mean yeah totally I don't you know
that people who come to see me same
things they sort of get it but I even
said that right everything in this stand
that right every everything that's out
I'm still dealing with the same taboo
issues and discussing them and you know
saying the wrong thing for comedic
effect ironically doing all the sounds
like harsher than ever probably but
because I set it up against an outraged
culture and against stupidly people and
Sonia they get it right but having said
that I've played this show - I don't
know how four hundred thousand people
never to complain right go on Netflix
and everyone will complain about their
thing sure there's take there's there's
twenty things I talked about and
there'll be 20
different groups that will pick on their
thing in that 20 not the 19 they didn't
care about but the thing they do carries
cure like like when someone gets sick
then they fight for the cure for that
disease yeah people just kind of care
about what they care for and you know
sometimes they are trying to get the
publicity in sometimes I think I'll wear
with your everyone thinks that their
thing they all say well it's different
okay well I do jokes about AIDS and
cancer and famine and Holocaust occur
yeah but they're different people don't
realize about this there's a prejudice
against this okay well there's pretty
much approach this against people who
are killed in the Holocaust it's like
everyone think no what why me why me
well it's not just you it's everyone
right so you've just but there's nothing
you do about that they are going to be
outraged and and I'm going to say well
you this is the joke this is how it
stands you know and and I don't know
what to do really
you just got to keep fighting the good
fight when you see stuff whether it I'd
say it's in the news or you get struck
with something and you're like oh I want
to talk about this like maybe it's the
Harvey Weinstein thing or maybe it's
just something you read on Twitter like
oh I want to talk about this does it get
frustrating because you're like well no
because I have my act and like that's
what I'm talking about there's nothing I
won't talk about how much time so yo you
cuz nice come to my club I explained it
well I I can stand by I can even stand
by if it gets outside of my club alright
um but I mean you'll add to this show
that you're doing like if there's
something you want to start talking
about that let me add to it uh or do you
just save it for the next one uh no I'll
um I'll probably allude to it because
you know there's things that that come
along that make the thing you're talking
about that's the same outdated right I'm
saying yes so and if you're talking
about the worst serial killer ever and
then someone breaks the record you have
to start squeezing stuff it's all
someone just killed him in America are
[ __ ] that joked funny
that name but doesn't it also get you
moving on new style I guess you start
squeezing out the [ __ ] from the back
ends like like toothpaste we're like the
new stuff starts coming in and then the
old stuff gets squeezed out the back and
then before you know it you got 20 new
minutes and you can drop 20 old minutes
and it's like you can almost keep
touring that way because by the you keep
adding keep adding and then before you
know you got a new 50 and ten old rates
and then it all just squeezes out yeah I
don't I don't really go topical because
I want it to be sort of more timeless so
quite a better than global as well you
know not all not all news is global and
not and and not all news is it is
topical a week later um so I I'm very
conscious of that as well but as I say
when you're dealing with AIDS cancer
family in the Holocaust sure they're not
going anywhere no longer a felony in LA
to expose someone knowingly to HIV yes
yes from my legal team tour if you know
your HIV and you you knowingly
potentially infect someone and you do
infect them you're you're not you should
be a felon but of course it should be a
felony but now the new California law I
guess because HIV is now stoppable
whatever the new penalties are they
reduce the penalty for not only exposing
someone HIV it's crazy they should IV
stoppable now yes what is how but
there's drugs you can take what you
can't spread it you know drugs you take
what doesn't you just keep oh I see but
you can't actually live for a long time
I wanted to ask you to you're playing a
suicidal guy in a Netflix series that
you created have you ever been or no
well suicidal no have you no so that
makes it that's what makes it such a
bigger thing that is no well the the the
premise of this the setup is that this
guy his wife dies after
you know an illness and obviously he's
depressed and angry and he thinks of
killing himself but he doesn't cause the
dogs hungry and it just snaps out long
enough and he thinks that he thinks that
was a you know okay love work and always
I can always kill myself so I won't yeah
it's what I've always got that in the
back pocket right I can always go there
so what I'm gonna do now to try and
enjoy life is I'm going to punish the
world but what happened I'm gonna say
what the [ __ ] I want
it's like a superpower so he goes I'm
gonna say what the I'm gonna say what
the [ __ ] I want until it gets all too
much and I can then I can still always
okay so that's brilliant cuz every day
is like his last day on earth every day
you just kill himself whatever you can
do what he wants yeah yeah and like all
superpowers it sort of gets it gets a
bit complicated sure because obviously
he's not a psychopath he is burdened
with conscience so even you know he's
got things like guilt and right you know
so so it's hard it's fight he finds it
hard to do exactly what he wants if you
know what I mean yeah so that that's
that's what it's all about
did you see it's different than the
movie with Jeff Bridges replays the guy
who survived a plane crash not the
vanishing it was it so I figured it's
cool he survives a play Rosie president
Benicio del Toro he survives a plane
crash and he feels like he's unkillable
he's in such shock from having survived
this plane crash that he he just kind of
goes on and just does whatever he wants
what he thinks he can't die oh really
uh well that's that that's that's the
luck is it delusional you mean he's like
he thinks he's he's just it's just does
he really think he can is it a breakdown
no it's a bit of a break fear he knows
he can die but but it's called fearless
where he just he lives life and like
this Hays almost where like every day is
like nothing matters anymore because you
didn't kill me so I can't die it's kind
of like all right right yeah but there's
a problem with it you know there's
always a problem with there's none of me
there's gotta be isn't there yeah for
drama yeah yeah I mean otherwise you're
just Superman and it's like this isn't
Superman without kryptonite it's not a
fun story also yeah that wins all the
first time insult so many get stabbed to
death that's great short just goes one
episode how upset would people be if the
new Ricky Gervais Sprott
was coming out on Netflix and they're
like no my Saturday is clear I know in a
binge watch no problem and you just turn
it on and yeah 30 seconds in looks great
in nine minutes
yes that's it I get snap the first scene
is useiess like you the suicide that you
see the homeless guy get a job and it
cuts you and you drop dead and the rest
of the episode is the wake and that's it
spend the money but you do get a
conscious you just feel bad saying
things that like hurt people like if you
say something hurts somebody it's like
yeah I know I'm not responsible but
there are times only uh I kind of feel
shitty about that if I because you don't
you don't want to be responsible for her
in anyone's feelings but there's a
difference between knowingly going out
and hurt an individual's feelings to
make them feel bad and saying something
in a stand-up show that if you found
10,000 people the person might have gone
through something like that and it
reminds them of that there's nothing you
can do about that you're not responsible
for that you're not you know and if
you're dealing with contentious issues
or dark subjects so um everything you
know you know I do a thing about I'm
imagining what the reason you've seen me
I don't know I don't have kids and I go
I agree I can I can you know I'd watch
it sleep you know yeah and and I'd do it
I'd do a thing about my map I don't want
my imaginary child to be born in case he
dies and stuff and and of course a
journalist said well what if someone in
the audience has lost a child I go well
yeah yeah well what but but what what's
the question really I don't I don't talk
about something that might have touched
someone else that's right that's crazy
and you know it's sort of you know it's
it's they're not gonna be pleasant
subjects I think I think that discussion
gets us through things if anything you
know as long as I'm not saying hands up
is lost a child
you yeah that's funny crushing those
hands up who's lost a child
[Laughter]
well you put the hands up in hands up in
parentheses for some reason hands up
who's lost a child just Ricky looking
like she no it's a picture the picture
is him on stage pointing its animation
Harvey Weinstein there's all this stuff
happen in Hollywood is like it's not
just him but this like this crazy effect
of all of these people being outed and
coming like did you see that type of
stuff at all or did you not notice any
of it like well this descent that
predecessor that was happening in
Hollywood like we were you able to see
any of that or is it just not that
apparent even when you're there a lot ah
no I'm not really part I'm not there I I
don't know I didn't really see it but I
assume I assume it goes on because it
goes on everywhere so it's you know but
now I haven't got any I haven't got any
oh I knew because I saw that's all that
no I you know I you know I go there
twice a year but for the Emmys and the
Golden Globes and but now I've and you
know obviously I'm not a young
vulnerable woman you know so I it's
there's a reason why I'm probably
encountered it I'm amazed by the petal
[ __ ] more than what the pedo stuff that
they talked about like there's all these
all these people that laid these
underground pedophilia like the sexual
harassment Alvin has been talking about
yeah for years and people laughed at him
people have to corey feldman barbara
walters you're hurting a whole industry
not to be fair they were laughing at
everything else corey feldman was doing
it's tough to deliver the message that's
that's a very good example so the first
somebody the golden globes
I did feel there or you shouldn't make
fun of these wonderful people and I just
thought [ __ ] that what you're talking
about I shouldn't matter the richest
most beautiful privileged people in the
world
I shouldn't tease them about yes I
should right I'm playing the court
jester I'm playing low status here I'm
I'm sticking it to NBC and the Golden
Globes and all the people who are being
honored and you know I'm
playing the fat guy at home so of course
I've got to write and evil at last year
I did a joke what was that film
spotlight uh-huh
I said spotlight great acclaim some said
exposure to I was Polanski calls it his
favorite date movie and there was you
know make fun of her were you to take
great so I when I did the joke about Mel
Gibson I liked a drink as much the next
man less than next - Mel Gibson there
was some comedian going on Mel Gibson's
a better director than Ricky Gervais I
wasn't having a go he's directing he's a
great director that's not the bother
joke Mel Gibson wasn't able to come back
here with a better joke yes and I've got
nothing against my lips and he's never
abused me right I don't mean but but
what I mustn't mention you know and I
kept it light and polite right you know
the thing that we all know and we see
now what did I go for I went a little
bit about him getting drunk and saying
an anti-semitic thing right right I
could have gone deeper as good of things
that I would have Mel Gibson drinking is
like the least of and again I do you
know McMahon when he's down and go but
it was just a joke
it was just fun you know I didn't I
wasn't trying to I wasn't even trying to
expose or bring down but the oh I
shouldn't go there why shouldn't you go
there so fraternity mentality I think
we're they're all just trying to kind of
cover everything up protect your own
until it's over and then you're out well
that is why it is Morgan you know
whatever you think it was Morgan
sometimes he gets it right he did a big
article with all these people going how
disgusting it is what everyone's saying
yes he's a monster he should be kicked
out of it and he should obviously but
then they're then they're given
Polanski with standing ovations right
well come on where's the [ __ ] let's
keep it a new girl just came out and
said that he he molest her when she was
10 porno minutes other girl yeah and the
problem here's why I don't like him made
fun of because when you do that it kind
of shames them over how funny they are
by protecting him it's almost like if
you make fun of Roman Polanski they all
have to acknowledge oh that's right
did [ __ ] a thirteen-year-old and we all
know it and we still line up to work
with him right but if a guy has you know
said something racist we'll will ban him
from the clock it depends what it is but
it is Israeli iftar how loved is how
important he was how good his work was
how recent the thing is since the work
was it during it before Patrice's bit
about Michael Jackson mm-hmm
can I can i still listen to thriller
maybe he wasn't doing bad I don't care
about but can I still listen to thriller
and people do make those little
decisions in their head I wonder all the
time like we see photos of the biggest
pop star in the world Rihanna and she's
just been beaten unmercifully about the
face and then within a year it's like oh
my god did you hear the new Chris Brown
song it's terrific I don't get it I
don't get up people that have short
memories in the hypocrisy and it's yeah
it I mean this isn't yeah what's that
Roman Polanski yeah I mean you know
accused we gotta be casual you know you
know that's but yeah you're right it's
that people make make make Allah people
make allowances depending on how much it
affects their life right they like if
they like the part I don't know anything
about that all the people that are new
and even people who admit and they knew
about Harvey Weinstein and now feel
guilty that they carried on working with
him you know people giving their stuff
to charity god I can't give her but I
want to go yeah but you made the
decision you made the decision yeah I
don't really I haven't seen it so maybe
I still can do this man I was seen it
you know Tarantino
like his girlfriend at the time Mira
Sorvino he was dating and she told him
what did it happen while they were data
it happened before he said mirrors has
told him she had something happened I
think it I think they have been working
more but she I'm saying she told him
while they were dating and like I mean
we have to be a bit careful with with
sores Asians and outrage because you
know is yes I until none of it's been
proven it's all but I mean some things
are a slam dunk you know it's really
weird too because over the weekend I
think at Friday Lupita Nyong'o
came out with a whole article describing
like what heart
it was near it and it was just great it
made me think even more because he was
talking she was talking about Harvey
bringing her to his house where his kids
were in Baba blah and I was like well if
that is true that probably means that
his wife had to kind of know what was
going on because you
but when again it's it's you know I feel
oh if she if she didn't know obviously
her and the victims are the victims you
know I always think of that I always
think that when someone has an affair
and I think oh my god the poor wife
she's being tricked you know I mean yeah
I think [ __ ] now but you've done
you've you've caused so much [ __ ] here I
bring it up because he came out and
denied it her story he was like he
released a statement yeah there was like
I remember things differently that
didn't really happen but he hasn't
denied any of the other stories that
I've seen it's kind of hard now to deny
them because that mean all the story
like loopiness story was the last one
does that mean all the other stories are
true James Toback is actually going I
didn't meet any of these women like is
Jackie's [ __ ] all in with his denial
there's like 30 women accusing him I
don't know them and I know that's almost
like I'm a germophobe would never think
to sexually assault somebody my excuse
again
this is a good example right because we
get flack here for discussing it and
maybe making like that we've certainly
done something wrong in some people's
eyes but we're trying to do it
intelligently and fairly and and that's
what worries me about the world that if
you can't do this intelligent fairly and
you know and with stay within the law
and not
unlike with anyone or I don't know I
don't know what really do not I mean
yeah it's it's it so people have a go at
people for being rude about someone
who's done terrible things
do you know I mean yeah oh hold on I did
a I did I handed out a BAFTA once and
there was a another actor which I won't
name right but he'd he'd just been done
for looking at child pornography okay I
think he denied it but I think he was he
was convicted and all that right so and
I went out and he'd won a BAFTA the year
before this guy right and so I went out
and handed out and I said damn I've the
great honour to hand out an award I said
I've won them I've won seven of these
myself it would have been a but BAFTA
preferred what so-and-so did to me right
because he won the BAFTA and and the
orders been [ __ ] and I went and I
looked at the BAFTA I said what can I
say he loves these shiny little thanks
and in the next day in this some paper
this posh bloke in some sort of posh
paper said the batter is wonderful Ricky
Gervais is brought the tone down by
smugly by smugly having a go at fellow
comedian I was thinking hold on you can
be smug about not watching child porn
yeah it's crazy it's honestly crazy like
the James Corden thing outraged now what
first thing I want to say about that was
it's not the subject
it's how bad the jokes were you know
there's the James Corden era that the
Harvey Weinstein's yeah oh yeah of
course yep you know and you know he
bouncing around
you know I think he thought he was gonna
be like edgy and are they gonna love me
for this I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
carried round going oh you're brilliant
you're brave Wow
but they were just so rushed and lame
and not thought out and the target
wasn't clear oh yeah that's the thing
about a joke it's a [ __ ] work of art
right a good joke is a work of art it
takes on everything it's it takes on
syntax semantics politics it comedy it
takes on everything and it comes out
perfect right and then if people don't
get it it's their problem but if if it's
flimsy and you haven't got the oven
that's sort of the targa out and you you
haven't delivered it well when it's like
if people go what the [ __ ] you doing
shouting I'm pay the files what yeah
yeah you think karaoke guy from the car
stand up or oh no he's not he just
hosted yeah yeah yeah that's tough yeah
I heard that's the other thing as well I
started I sometimes uh you know I wanted
a tweet um I talked about contentious
issues all the time but I want to end
with please don't try this at home and I
want to say it's not easy I can't go up
there is did you you can't go up there
and just saying I think in people go I
was fine no it's got to be good you've
got to know what you're doing it's a
it's walking a tightrope putting telling
a joke about a really content and the
more emotive and context the issue is
the harder it is for people to laugh
however good Joe's so the jokes gotta be
[ __ ] amazing do you not I mean yes
absolutely it's unless you're talking to
a room for the Psychopaths then it's got
to be really really good you know
there's nothing worse than there's
nothing worse when you missed the mark
I'm like a what it's a bad subject like
pedophilia I did something on stage I
was making fun of Harvey Weinstein the
other night and I was saying how they
praised Roman Polanski and I said
something about cuz all he did was
[ __ ] thirteen-year-old it and then it
got no laughs and I went I pretty much
just stayed the sad fact I just I stated
the fact that was sad like what do I
expect applause for recognizing good
point stupid we know yeah yeah yeah of
course you've got but you know that
that's why those things aren't they're
probably not great do I'd live about
right because you haven't worked out
yes saying I don't know how to do it
right those golden glow jokes you know I
make sure every word counts you know
it's equipted clue a gag it's you know I
mean it's a piece of poetry every word
counts like then the most famous one
I did a joke and like ten years ago in a
special and III set it up like um it was
talked about drink drive and I said I I
don't even drive by the way okay I said
to him yeah I am I had a drink one Chris
was gonna flip the car out and I knew it
was wrong and I learned my lesson though
because I nearly killed an old woman
right I know in the end I didn't kill
her in the end I just right there right
now that is clearly a pun on nearly
right so I even even in the joke I do a
thing of swerving the wheel I nearly
killed no lady right in the end of the
unit and the pun is so oh so the nearly
isn't narrowly missing her it's getting
out and brutally attacking okay so and
people got that right and the paper
wrote up saying up Ricky Gervais his
disgusting joke he says um I said I went
out in a nearly killed an old lady in
the end I just raped her no joke at all
right no joke just Ricky describing and
evening they missed the joke okay they
missed the joke that you know and it
people don't realize how important every
[ __ ] word intonation context is it's
it's it's paramount it's it's anything
ruins a joke and changes it and
therefore changes the point of a joke
and the I think the politics of a joke
you know you get a joke wrong you are
you are [ __ ] evil if you you know I
mean yes for saying some that joke is
[ __ ] awful because one it's not a
joke - it's not mine you know it right
it's yeah I'm glad I mean it's it's kind
of along the same lines but that you're
doing a show on Sirius we haven't talked
about the shows coming too serious
because so often you know we talk about
people who don't know how to get on
stage and tell jokes but so often like
you know famous people come to Sirius
and they start hosting radio shows and
they don't have a clue what they're
doing and the radio shows are always
terrible and it's like what do we
doing here but I love that you're coming
on board because like you were one of
the first successful podcasters like
this is a medium that you've actually I
love it explored and I love affected and
it's a great medium because it's just
chat and there's there's there's no
there's no better medium than talking
right nothing will ever beat that right
as to communicate ideas feelings truth
it's it's it's it's all we've got left
freedom of speech is our greatest
privilege and it's gonna save humanity
and I think if you get you know a group
of thoughtful intelligent people in a
room you can talk about anything
and it would be interesting to eavesdrop
in you know or even join in and and add
that music which is to me the greatest
art form in the world and comedy which
is one of the reasons to stay alive I
can't believe my luck I absolutely love
it and and you helped me with the pilot
and it was great it was it was it was
really great and but you know you've got
your own show but um and it was really
fun and I just wanted to test the waters
that I could still talk and it's so
funny in the pilot because I start off
saying yeah I don't talk to you I people
have Richard Dawkins and I talked about
the universe and space and the reason we
live big issues in that and then
immediately we were onto a pile of
decapitated testicle yeah alright I felt
like I had really taken the dick in the
bar way down and we have Sam here and
Simon we're the balls and and Sam was
talking about a things he says Americans
powder their balls with town yeah you
know he said cuz its to combat the
dude's mouth yeah but he also hates the
taste
you know maybe powdering ball I've done
I've done that I thought I felt a stir
but the years ago I do now my balls are
sealed
[ __ ] 17th century French what do you
mean you powder I didn't watch when I
was drinking I was wearing army pants I
was sweating okay to let the ravenous
squeezing into a leather
I was just know as drunk at my balls
were sweaty and disgusting so my powder
doesn't they just turned to like a paste
it didn't help because a girl went down
on me in her
you are sitting on our patio chair much
information this would happen too much
so we're talking in the nebulous yeah a
weird serial killer creeping in and
cutting off your bows he has a real
story about story ironic laughter but
I've told the story about many it's a
you you want a powder balls story I got
one well they were smelly and I put
powder on them what were they smelling
on they were just reeking of teenage boy
confusion and desperation and sweat it
was Miller you know shame lot of it I
knew so many got like it used to be a
thing like you first guys would get
deodorant and they're like you know and
you're starting to go through puberty
and everything and then by high school I
was so confused by it because I never
did it but I feel like of course you
powder your balls you have to powder
your I just have two showers a day it
sorts that sometimes a bath right that's
that's a I've never I've never gone off
at me my posting I've never done that
I've never thought [ __ ] me my ball stink
what am I gonna do stuck in the jungle
for sure what's that smell because we
can't sleep at night I've never ever had
a problem doctor what is it what is it
doctor um oh what's that smell
that's what I'm here for doctor it's my
ball they smell other things like if you
ever doing situps and thought lost
someone spilled sour milk no I've never
I've never had the problem with smelly
bowls I was actually surprised that you
didn't know of like when I was like yeah
you know guys part of their balls and
you're like what are you talking about
like what are you talking about well I
suppose we'll new I suppose in that I
don't know maybe when I was a baby oh
yeah sure when your baby I dunno I'm not
the Bose Seco you're 28 when's the first
time you remember your armpits stinking
do you remember that the first time you
notice like oh I stink
probably at school after playing
football in my uniform and then sitting
around in it and yeah [ __ ] something's
jamming the first time wearing white
t-shirt what the [ __ ] is that
yeah old old sweats bad innit
oh yeah I said
you enter an airport and you go Jesus
Christ where people have been on stuck
on a plane for 20 out and they come out
and an airport can reek of can be oh I
know it's a horrible smell I think the
worst smell the worst smell worse than
anything right [ __ ]
sweat smegma anything sure
is halitosis a real bad halitosis that's
the worst I can it like it takes the
[ __ ] oxygen out your lung yeah delete
the other three are great fetishes the
only sexual website that doesn't exist
it's been a while but I used to go to
like pro wrestling conventions where
like old wrestlers go and they sign
autographs and fans pay to go here
everything did you swap train numbers
the crowd it gets drawn is like yes the
most flatulence and your body odor that
stays in the room and halitosis yeah and
all unwashed hair yeah all of it just
inside one hotel go to go to a car go to
a cat show and that's some that's a hell
of a gene pool I'll bet the crossover
between people who like wrestling and
people who go to car shows obviously I'd
bring my why and I guess when you're
there like because you chose to be there
you kind of can convince yourself to
ignore it but like I bring my wife was
my girlfriend at the time yeah what the
[ __ ] is that smell where you taking me I
want to show you that I'm not a freak
look in with his symmetry symmetrical
face how the parts where they shake I'm
gonna tell my wife to watch they get old
wrestler to sign some guy that's a
really weird day I did really would be
standing on waiting just bathing in the
filth and the stench Travis Bickle was a
better movie day so um so your teenager
you have disgustingly smelly testicles
one reason one time
recognized and I put powder on them and
then they blew me sitting on her back
patio furniture and I'll never forget I
dropped my pants and she started the
tour have you ever have you ever thought
oh I can't tell that story doesn't even
come close we know when you were sort of
coming of age right when did you start
thinking about sex or like eleven twelve
like everyone else yeah yeah me apply
around there and did you go oh my god
that's I can't have those thoughts I
can't I can't go down that road did you
ever think I've got to sort my life out
because I'm thinking some really [ __ ] I
don't mean to embarrass you because you
can't it's [ __ ] impossible I found
out just recently that when Jim was a
kid yeah he had in him and a couple of
his other guy friends they used to stand
around and this is like young and they
would trade sucks oh oh you mean what do
you think I meant yeah the trade sucked
we would uh it's not a statement
okay trade products like yeah like you
give me 20 and I'll give you 20 talk
like that I know I know they weren't
guys that's what's weird about if
someone talked about eating sauerkraut
it's not your food of course to be like
how old were you though 23 no I was
probably like this I was abused before
fourth grade so I'd say like that that's
the second grade third grade seven eight
oh that doesn't count then it's like
seven years old second age that was
there any idea I used to I used to a
similar story except it wasn't dicks it
was sort of like sort of football cards
we used to Train
mm-hmm so no I got that what I need that
though I remember one bloke said um do
wanna trade sucks I go down and I just
do let's just do the cards for now and
someone suggests it not one other person
goes one guy well you got to make it
sound cool right like one guy starts
taking his pants down and the other guys
like what are you doing and he's like
we're not gonna trade socks are you guys
cool like think of that right I've
always thought of this when I see like
I'm three men have been arrested for
abducting a child right I think old on
when they're in the pub right is this
what you want to do one says trying to
go to the match I don't know what's
telling other words you want abduct a
child and the other two go yeah what's
the chances starts that conversation
listen do they did he try it five times
like and I go what I'm joking I'm joking
until he find the right - I mean I'm
kidding I'm kidding joking I'm sure and
I'm sure in every group there's like one
guy who's like I know I was just going
along with it I didn't realize we are
now we're in trouble
I know I mean it happens now because the
[ __ ] dark web what is the dark web
why is there a dark web why is traceable
Internet but how about how do people
know about it do you have to do this you
need a certain browser or browser tor
browser I don't know how you find the
sites I don't know if they have a Google
version on that like I don't I don't
know I don't know much about that but
apparently people don't do it for the
reasons that of that monsters they're
just stealing movies or music is the
same thing is it always see we're trying
to buy drugs or drugs always for hire
I mean there's literally like their
stores set up on the dark web where you
can just go and buy heroin and cocaine
just like and it's not like label this
it's just like it's delivered yeah they
send a FedEx but hold on though if
anyone knows about it why aren't is this
a naive question why aren't the FBI
looking and go they do they do and they
started it but then this other guy
starts hitting this other guy and it's
way more difficult to to track because
all the IPS get blocked yeah there's a
way for them to do it with like bundles
of stuff that's going out of but it's
like oh yeah yeah Jana to get my iPhone
up once a Jane went to Brighton to see a
mum one night and I couldn't use the
remote she had to send me a little
drawing of the remote control to tell me
which buttons to press in order to get
the TV on there's a lot of photos of her
all by herself I just I just hang back
and just go and just go and when there's
no one around okay Jay with all the -
you're out walking you should look
around realise there's nobody wait a
minute a little paparazzi was right I
forget what it was but there's something
like she was holding her phone and the
captures nope no calls
[Laughter]